Частково відшкодувати батькам гроші, витрачені на нянь,
має намір прем’єр-міністр Володимир Гройсман.
На думку прем’єра, таким чином родина зможе зекономити трохи грошей.
В середньому, за даними фахівців, професійна няня
отримує 70-80 гривень за годину роботи у великих містах в Україні.
В місяць виходить від 10 до 15 тисяч гривень.
У регіонах - удвічі менше. Уряд же планує виплачувати
лише близько 1500 гривень на місяць, ця сума
дорівнює прожитковому мінімуму для дітей до шести років.
У майбутньому вона зростатиме, але не суттєво і не різко.
Як йдеться в урядовому ролику, серед головних вимог
для отримання держдопомоги - дитині має бути до трьох років,
а з нянею має бути укладена офіційна угода про працевлаштування.
Останнє -  найпроблемніше. Абсолютна більшість нянь в Україні
працюють в "тіні", говорять фахівці ринку,
оскільки не бажають платити податки.
Наприклад, уявімо, що зарплата няні у маленькому містечку
дорівнює передбаченій бюджетом мінімальній - 3723 гривень.
Відраховуємо від цієї суми Єдиний соціальний внесок (819 грн),
який за законом сплачує роботодавець, та податок
на доходи фізичних осіб (670 грн), який сплачує робітник.
Але ймовірно, що платити за все муситиме лише няня.
Оскільки батьки не є роботодавцями або
податковими агентами, пояснюють юристи.
Таким чином, навіть за мінімальними підрахунками
отримана компенсація повертається державі.
Окрім того, держава зобов’язується виплачувати
компенсацію не щомісяця, а лише в кінці року.
Тобто весь рік батьки все одно муситимуть шукати гроші на няню власноруч.
А враховуючи те, що старт програми запланований на 1 січня наступного року,
перші виплати почнуться фактично лише на початку 2020-го.
Тобто вже після президентських виборів.
а думку експертів, це дуже нагадує так звану "юліну тисячу",
коли у 2009 році прем’єрка Юлія Тимошенко
роздавала по тисячі гривень вкладникам Ощадбанку СРСР.
Ще більше запитань в експертів щодо того, звідки
візьмуться кошти на "муніципальну няню".
Програма не дарма так називається.
За задумом Гройсмана, лише чверть компенсації йтиме з держбюджету,
решта - з обласних та місцевих бюджетів.
Таким чином проблема ДЕ і ЯК дістати кошти
на компенсацію перенесена на місцеву владу.
Частково компенсувати витрати родин на няню -
ідея гарна, але навряд чи це допоможе батькам .
зекономити кошти, вважають експерти
Окрім того це не виведе нянь з "тіні"
і не стимулюватиме сплачувати податки.
Також ідея з "муніципальною нянею", на думку експертів,
схожа на передвиборний популізм очільника уряду Володимира Гройсмана.